i feel like a failure man you want to
slow it down a little bit no
no
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by ed sheeran
he's a four-time grammy award-winning
singer-songwriter who sold more concert
tickets and albums than just about any
other musician over the last decade
or really any decade for that matter and
good news for ed sheeran fans as we have
a new single album and tour on the way
let's celebrate with a flight of
extremely spicy chicken wings shall we
ed sheeran welcome to the show thanks
for having me
i know that you have a passion for
ketchup how are you around the hot sauce
i'm all right actually i'm alright but i
think in england like the spice is
it's just so different to america like
in america i feel like you get like two
chilies and breed them to make this like
super chilly that
will [ __ ] you up whereas in england it's
kind of just like
just i guess like normal children we do
have carolina reapers and
uh yeah i think like the curry situation
over there can get
quite intense and my go-to curry is like
one below the really intense one so i
hope
i hope i'm all right
[Music]
okay so this is just regular buffalo
it's still got something though isn't it
it's not like totally mild
[Music]
that's great so as we mentioned up top
you are as you put it
coming out of hibernation with a
forthcoming album and i'm really curious
how an artist decides to pick the first
single like when you're looking at an
album and seeing that track list what is
your internal math when deciding
which one to introduce to fans first
especially after a hiatus yeah i think
for me
it's every time i've released a first
single the way that it works best is to
do something
to like ground that i've never covered
before because i feel like
as an as a fan of musicians like any
time that anyone's like
not reinvented themselves but come out
with something that you're like oh my
god i didn't expect them to do that i
think that's
usually the way i picked the first
single and it's kind of like a catch-22
because you put something out
and your core fan base goes he's changed
he's
going in this new direction and then
suddenly the album comes out and they're
like oh actually in the in the grand
scheme of things i mean it happened my
second album i did a song called sing
and then the third album i did a song
called shape of you and both times
everyone was like this is this is too
different and both times both songs
worked and led into the album quite well
so this
this time i had a first single pick kind
of like lo-fi depressing sad
and i'd made this like really upbeat
dance tune
and then boris johnson announced that
england was opening up on the 21st of
june
and my single was going to come out on
the 25th of june
so i sort of switched them around
because i was like what what
what do i want to hear on the radio when
the world opens up or if clubs are going
do i want to hear like a really
depressed
li-fi acoustic gene yeah
[Music]
they're good they're really tasty so
there are a lot of stories about pop
stars breaking through
by uploading covers to youtube but your
breakthrough on the platform is really
unique with their first viral hit being
a performance on
sbtv yeah thinking back how did the uk
hip-hop scene and grime artist what
impact or effect do you think it had on
the trajectory of your career especially
early on
well i think you know i moved to london
sort of like
turning 17 and i joined the like
acoustic singer-songwriter set
so like went to do the shows and then i
would meet other singer songwriters and
then you just get part of this circuit
i was like 17 18 most of them were like
25 26 and much better than me so i would
do a show
and just kind of be forgotten about and
i was doing the same shows with the same
people
at the same venues with the same songs
and just nothing was happening
a friend of mine who was a poet um lived
in los angeles and she said look i can
get you a gig in
um los angeles if you can sort the
ticket and i'd been selling cds over a
couple of months the ticket was like 800
quid
i bought the ticket i flew over to la
the thing i played was a poetry gig
and it was in uh inglewood
it was called fly poet i arrived there
and i was british the only white guy in
the room with a guitar with like crazy
hair and i was like [ __ ] i don't think
today's going to go well i stood up on
stage and i played the songs and it was
the best reaction i'd ever got from
any show i think because it was all
poetry and rap and suddenly like someone
sits up and sings a song about you know
a
homeless girl in in london people kind
of connected to it so from there
when i got back to england i was like
i'm not going to do any more acoustic
nights i'm going to do comedy nights i'm
going to do rap nights i'm going to do
jazz nights and i basically
did that circuit met jamal who ran sp tv
and like within a year
it kicked off so for me the uk
i guess it's not an underground scene
anymore because it is the the forefront
of
of culture but at the time the uk
underground scene was
the sort of catalyst for me having
success here
[Music]
it's all right so this is where khaled
tapped out
right right you got it in you to keep
going
dude if i stopped now i would never hear
the end of it
never i'm making it i'm making it to the
last one
there's a bit of an aftertaste to that
one it does it kind of builds in you
if i go for water is that like a failure
no no no no no
you know if you hit the water or the uh
the milk
i'm only having this because i'm thirsty
so there's a scene in your documentary
songwriter we can see that you're
visibly frustrated by
changes that were made to your song
shape of you and you say
i promise you it'll sound better this
way in a manner that made me really
feel the self-will of your creative
conviction
is there another example of a song that
you think was made better by doing
what you wanted to do despite the
feedback and wishes of those around you
yeah i guess i mean i i've i've been
wrong in a lot of cases and i've been
writing
a lot of cases and i think the key to it
is having people that you listen to and
not being like i know everything so with
shape of you
didn't want to put that on my album i
thought it doesn't sonically fit i don't
i've made this album it's perfect in my
mind i don't want to put this on
and everyone will say if you put this on
it would be the biggest hit of your
career and i was like no
it's just i kind of felt it was like
cheating because it i basically had done
a paint by numbers
pop tune and i sort of felt like i was
cheating with that
and um it was it was the biggest hit of
my career and i love playing it live i
love seeing the reaction it has to
people and i hear it
everywhere so i was wrong there but
there's also like i know
the people involved will deny this to
the hilt but there is no
way that i would have given this song
away if no one liked it or if people
liked it but
when i wrote justin bieber's love
yourself i remember playing that to
people and then being like
and so i gave it away and now it's like
why did you give it away you know you
never played this to us i had an email
actually the other day
from a song that i'd gone round this
bloke's house and i'd played him this
song three times
and played it on acoustic guitar and
then i came to america i played it to a
couple of people
they emailed him and then he emailed me
being he got the song he's like what the
[ __ ]
this is the best song we have on the
album this is the thing and i was like
dude i literally played this to you
three times a week ago
and you you weren't feeling it then it's
yeah it's very much like
they say how many uh how many music
industry people does it take to change a
light bulb 1
and 99 to ask each other what they think
of it that's basically it
so is this like is this one you sell in
shops yeah yeah we actually make this
one
that's really tasty we'll take that
everyone buy that
okay we actually have a very special
surprise for you on this wing we reached
out to a mutual friend who's
brought us burning questions that he has
for you ed sheeran can you guess who it
is i can see who it is it's benny blanco
that's right it's five-time bmi
songwriter of the year benny blanco
also the host of eat out america he's
got some questions for you
he's gonna say he can really i know he's
gonna say something [ __ ] up
well let's see the first one what's your
favorite song
we've ever worked on together
why is he saying normal questions i was
expecting him to say something green
um i would say castle and hill castle on
the hill for me was the um it was the
first tune that i finished for the
divide and it was like the the sort of
like
benchmark that all the other songs went
went around and we wrote it here in new
york
i think we worked in a jessie ware song
and i went in to do some like backing
vocals or something on that and we just
did it
on the side and then it ended up being
like the kind of
thing that made the album happen well
there you go all right it's starting to
spiral it gets more benny as we work
good good good name one artist that
you're so
[ __ ] jealous of like you look at
their stats all the time you wish your
[ __ ] was as good as theirs
you just you you can't put out records
without even
thinking about them i wouldn't say i'm
actually
like jealous of of anyone because i feel
like i
love what i do and i couldn't do what
what other people do but i think every
artist when they release
finds out whether drake taylor or adele
are releasing and they go what like what
what
what day they going and like should we
can we put out i think every artist does
that
but i wouldn't say i'm jealous of any of
them but all of them make me
strive to work harder well all right one
more for you
it's a big mystery all right for
everyone who doesn't know
me and ed real good friends we went to a
festival stayed up all night
came back got in a jacuzzi together and
he pissed it
and someone
peed in the jacuzzi it was fun it was me
ed
ryan tedder i'll tell you why maybe one
other person
ed has been convinced that i pissed in
the jacuzzi it's not any
wait i'll tell you offices just for
everyone around the world
i i do piss in pools exactly
but i don't piss in jacuzzis i would
never piss in a body of water that small
ed i need to know do you believe me or
not
so he's been going on about this for a
while so i think okay so it it
might be tedder it might be but the
thing is benny said to me
as he arrived at my house i'm going to
pee in your pool
and i was like you're not going in my
[ __ ] pool benny if you're going to
pee
pick me he's like i'm going to pee in
your pool so just never let him in the
pool we went to a festival
latitude festival we came back to my
house and we're sitting in the jacuzzi
and then like a couple of weeks later i
go to use it [ __ ] stinks
and i get someone to check out the
cruise people come check it out and they
said it had so much urine in it that it
had over
overflown the system that like cleans
the urine so
it is either benny or tedder but only
one person told me that they would pee
in my pool
and it was this company
we were in there for hours soaking in
someone's earring
[Music]
this is a really pleasant morning so far
so far that one's the best one so far
we'll take that we'll take that
commission on that yeah i got a little
rupture on it
all right we actually have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham we're doing a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context
so we'll pull up the picture over here
on the monitor you just tell us the
bigger story
where does doing a song with 50 cent and
eminem your song
remember the name where does that fall
on your list of career accomplishments
i think probably top three because when
i was in school
i i mean look at me if you would if you
were to f
like i looked like that in school but
younger smaller skinnier and geekier
and if you were to go into my school and
go at the height of shady records and
the height of aftermath
and go which one of these kids is going
to do a song with m m and 50 cent
no one would no one would have guessed
me and like i've done a song with um
for his album and then i was like i'm
putting together collaborations project
i sort of said to him could you could
you do it i'd love to get 50 on it and
he was like yeah
no problem i'll get 50 on it and i
remember walking into this dressing
50 will probably disagree with this but
i remember walking into the wembley
dressing room
to me and we were being presented to
play and i don't think 50 had a [ __ ]
clue who i was he was
i think afterwards he was like oh the
shape of you guy but like i was kind of
like hey and
you could see in his eyes he was like
i'm not and i
at this point we'd actually done the
song together but um
he'll probably disagree with that though
[Music]
mild oh well this one does kind of
creep yep
i know this one's [ __ ] up i know that
one's [ __ ] up you've had that one
before i've got that in my cupboard yeah
whoa yeah i have a whole cupboard my
wife's made me actually
move them all because they were in the
normal cupboard and i kept buying hot
sauces so she's made me have my own
cupboard for
the hot sauces that fill them up and now
you have some more to add to it so these
are all mine you get to take them
[ __ ] yeah thank you can i get a couple
of the last dabs i promised my driver
geo i'd give them yeah yeah we'll hook
it up we'll hook it up
so there are these amazing stories about
your dedication from acquiring james
blunt's diary so that you could set a
benchmark for how hard you need to work
just doing over 300 it does it does
creep to doing over 300 gigs in 2009
alone
is doing stage shows still the best way
for a singer-songwriter to build
experience and get discovered or is that
path to success more or less given way
to the internet
yeah i think i think in music
everything's a muscle that you have to
keep
exercising whether it's songwriting
whether it's singing i like
i've never really done vocal warm-ups
and um since getting back to work now
i'm starting to lose my voice again and
i'm kind of like do i do vocal warm-ups
why didn't i do them before and i think
it's because i sung
every day whether it's stage whether
it's songwriting or singing or
performing in general
you just have to do it all the time i've
noticed you've not touched your water or
your milk you know it's not as any sort
of like a show-off thing it's just i've
been so
uh i've been so captivated do you
actually distract the same wings that i
get
yeah i would i don't just get all mild
no no
no no you can see see you can see the
coloration
and differences go ahead go ahead just
making sure
i i i'm open to it i'm open to it all
right are you ready to move on here to
the next wing
this is love burns here in the seventh
spot
i feel like i feel like saying that that
was miles
like it heard that and came back to bite
me
it's gonna get weird here okay
it's like a dry heat i think this one's
gonna be a creeper in it
and it builds yeah from all fronts
[Music]
righto florida
[Music]
say no no no they don't play
so once i post a retro martin guitar
from 1907 of all the instruments in your
collection
which is the oldest and what's its
backstory probably
that probably that i'd say the coolest
one was um
um so actually the guy that told me to
do this show
i got sorry i'll i'll explain story i
basically my hero is eric clapton he's
the reason i started playing guitar
and um i uh saw him on tv when i was 11.
i picked up guitar i learnt later and
kind of went from there
i got to know him in like 2015 and we've
been friends since
and i went to his house and we had like
noodles or something
then afterwards he just took his guitar
off the wall and just gave it to me
signed the back and said keep my guitar
and i was like [ __ ] cool
kept it in my studio at home it was my
the only guitar in my studio at home
i was on tour the person that lives in
my house rolled me off and was like
[ __ ] music studios on fire it's
burning to the ground we've got the
fiber grade here i was like i was like
[ __ ] the guitar's in that studio anyway
the guitar comes out it's ruined it's
black it's like burnt to a crisp
um and the guy that i was working with
who have done the record with joe
hi joe i know you're [ __ ] watching he
says
give me the guitar let me see what i can
do with it and so he took it and about a
year later he brought it back and it'd
been
totally restored and it smells it smells
like a burnt house it's like but this
really really burnt
wood smell but it plays amazing looks
amazing
actually smells amazing and still has
eric's signature on
on the back so that's like my favorite
couture
i told you same wings yeah they're
[ __ ] up man
and this one as you know it's [ __ ] up
[Music]
crush on a bike
that's just the beginning as well right
just growing from here yep don't worry
this one is where does your day go from
here
me i've actually come to kind of look
forward to
and enjoy the post hot ones experience
because it's a time that i can tell
everybody
to kind of leave me alone you know no
phone calls no emails
crank the air conditioning in my
apartment have a little ice cream and
chill
[ __ ] help man so speaking of crazy
eating i know that
you've switched up your diet habits
quite a bit since the early carefree
tour days but i love hearing these
stories about you taking like
butter masala and mixing them with
vindaloo sauce or ordering three
different kinds of puddings and turning
them into one uber dessert
is there an off menu ed sheeran
frankenstein
restaurant request that you're most
proud of [ __ ] help
i think my local kebab shop do like oh
my god can we just eat the rest of it
just eat these [ __ ]
man that's bad that's bad that's bad i
know that you went to that
michelin-starred
sushi joint giro in tokyo was that the
religious restaurant experience that
everybody says that it is
no it was good it was good but there's a
sushi place in
london called iraqi it's kind of the
same thing it's like
i think eight eight seats on my cassette
bloke just handing it to you and that i
preferred that experience more than jira
i think yeah jiro is
like that ten seats 18 minutes no
talking thing
yeah and and they charge you a thousand
dollars at the end of it
all right heather you're ready to move
on
more almond milk there but i feel like
i'm i feel like i've i feel like a
failure man
you want to slow it down a little bit no
no
at this point i think you see the finish
line you're going through
has anyone done it with a straight face
there have been some times where people
seem totally unaffected
[Music]
after the bomb i think it's like
a little bit easier the bombers do i
think joe actually gave me that one
the bomb yeah shout out to joe shout out
to joe
he watches every single one actually he
was like gung-ho for having you having
gordon ramsay on him i remember the day
you had gordon on he was like i think we
were in studio and he stopped it and was
like we're watching this
oh not as bad as the bum still [ __ ] up
so you have a knack for surprising fans
whether it's taking taylor swift to your
local pub and family on or hopping on
stage in a random mall for a fan
that's singing thinking out loud on
stage do you have an all-time favorite
sort of
ed in the wild experience it's an
interesting question all right
actually my village i live in there's
like 400 people
and they don't really
[Music]
oh they don't really have like i'm kind
of like the only guy that lives there
that people
would know or like seeing on tv and like
when i
bring people down it's quite random i
remember i had courtney cox to come and
stay
and she thought that tesco which is a
supermarket like walmart or whatever
it was like a farmer's market and
someone had said we're going to tesco
and she was like
i'll go to i love farmers markets i'll
go and so it's like
the supermarket with just local people
who like went to my high school or
whatever and they suddenly see
monica from friends like looking at
dolmio pastors or whatever
and i quite like stuff like that it's so
far from london that it's not normal
that you would see people it's like
totally out of the ordinary
all right ed i feel like there's like
some questions i don't even remember
answering
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around you
extra [ __ ] hell i'm the last one you
don't have to if you don't like me i'm
not
i have a northern irish friend that says
if you're going to get done for knicking
a horse you might as well [ __ ] it
don't try that i hope you guys might
take the tagline
oh is that enough that's enough that's
funny that's funny that's funny
all right guys
i have to say man i'm not saying this
because it's your show
but those were the two tastiest ones by
far
you enjoyed the last ad yeah i did even
after going through
that that is the worst by far by far
i'm right with you on that i was like i
was good good good good good good good
no these two all right that one no
[Music]
well thankfully ed we're at the
conclusion of our spicy chicken wing
adventure and we're hoping
that we can close things out with a bang
back in 2012 you told complex
i'm not the world's best or worst beat
boxer
what is the first beat that materializes
within you when you think about
conquering the wings of death today
that's the beat an ed sheeran exclusive
taking on the hot ones gauntlet and
living to tell the tale
crushing the almond milk and slaying the
wings
now ed sheeran there's nothing left to
do but roll out the red carpet for you
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
um not a lot not a lot
bad habits new single out now tour next
year album in the autumn
check them out thank you
[Applause]
it's an amazing concept of a show dude
i've like
doing promo it's kind of you get into
the rhythm of just doing
interviews and doing questions and like
every now and then someone will throw
something and it's
actually genuinely fun
hey what's going on everybody this is
sean evans and would you take a look at
how we've set the table take
a look at this this is the hot ones
oxford pennant collab a classic american
company
buffalo new york in fact shout out to
bill
these right here they're perfect for the
dorm room they're perfect
for the hot ones party that you're
throwing at your place perfect for the
sports cave
to get yours visit
shop.firstviewfeast.com that's
shop.firstbefeast.com to get your hands
on the hot ones
oxford pennant careful around the eyes
you